welcome back let's get reaction to my
in-depth and exclusive interview with
Rudy Giuliani from our own all-star
panel a role reversal for a special
report anchor and chief political anchor
Bret bear in New York tonight he's the
author of the huge new yes soon-to-be
bestseller New York Times three days in
Moscow Ronald Reagan and the fall of the
Soviet empire and in Raleigh former
whitewater deputy independent counsel
Saul Weisenberger gentlemen great to see
both of you saw let's start with you
what did you take away from that
interview with Rudy well I look at
everything like this this kind of an
interview at the performance level and
the substantive level at the performance
level I think he did a very good job
this is what he should have done the
from the very beginning when he was on
Sean's show he was much more polished he
knew much more so that was very good
many of his statements were interact and
some of them were preposterous and some
of them were just arguments and opinions
but there's no way that the person under
investigation or his attorney gets to
say it's been a year that's too much but
again in terms of performance I thought
he did pretty well let's play the first
soundbite guys from this interview which
is the question of whether the President
himself can be indicted let's watch the
same reason they can't indict him they
can't issue a subpoena tip and remember
Clinton opposed a subpoena and then he
voluntarily complied he didn't give up
presidential prerogative and then his
administration wrote a memo saying they
can't do that Brett it's interesting
Judge Andrew Napolitano made a point
earlier today and he said when Muller
supposedly said Mellors team said we're
not going to indict the president
because we're gonna stand by this you
know this Justice Department advisory
opinion that you can't indict a sitting
president when Napolitano said this was
a 1999 advisory opinion it wasn't
binding so if Muller wanted to change
his approach on that he could which I
found interesting yeah and I thought
that was a fascinating part of the
interview I think you know Rudy is
hanging on to that that that
the team may have told him that about
the indictment and staying to the
guidelines from back in in the Clinton
years however his answer suggested that
there they're getting ready for a fight
over a possible subpoena and whether
that's legitimate and how they could
fight that if they don't want the
President to sit down under the
guidelines that they set up and Saul you
heard him at the end you know let them
put what put on the table what they have
you know will we agree or disagree with
the grounds or legitimate or
illegitimate we don't think they're
legitimate we're gonna take him to court
on these issues and he said we'll rip it
apart and we'll rip them apart that's
kinda that's kind of like one-upsmanship
on the on the threats game but yeah a
right on performance that was good but
what about the substance of that point
that he made on the subpoena oh he's
completely wrong I mean the first
subpoena issued and served on a
president was by John Marshall on Thomas
Jefferson in 1807 there was a subpoena
served on Madison and of course we all
know about the subpoena served on
President Nixon by Leon Jaworski and the
Supreme Court ruled 8 to nothing that
the President had to obey it now so he's
utterly completely wrong in the OLC
opinion to my knowledge only talks about
whether or not you can indict a
president by the way President Clinton
didn't fight the subpoena from a judge
star he asked us to withdraw it and said
he would come if we did and that's what
happened we don't know if we would have
fought it I don't think he would have
fought it now
if he is subpoenaed and invokes
executive privilege that is president
Trump and a court rules against him he
can say like Andrew Jackson supposedly
said you know you've made your law Chief
Justice Marshall now see if you can
enforce it and then Supreme Court has
said twice that orders have to be obeyed
in Cooper versus Aaron and in US versus
Nixon but he could say that's
interesting I'm the president I'm a
co-equal branch and I'm not going to do
it and then we'd have a really
interesting constitutional crisis on our
hands Brett the part of the interview
where he's I brought up the issue of
staffers because we know the special
counsel has
in a number of the clothes staff a
former staff of the President of the
United States and this is how the
discussion went let's watch are you
concerned about any of the former Trump
White House staffers I know hope Hicks
her name was thrown around and in
working with Don Jr maybe on the
statement about the Trump Tower meeting
are you worried about her conversations
at all with the special counsel god that
would be really cheap but he's turning
the screws on people if they did that to
her
then a just problem would have to step
in and act because it would be just that
total injustice listen you have Jim
Comey who told me that he didn't know
what this this whole thing about Michael
Flynn was but lawmakers saying that he
told them that the FBI agents didn't
believe that Michael Flynn was lying yet
the screws were put onto Michael Flynn
and he eventually pled guilty and and
and you know and and they've moved
forward so you can imagine the screws
being put potentially to a lot of these
other staffers who have done interviews
I think the politics of this is really
interesting I can see the comfort that
perhaps President Trump has in Rudy
Giuliani being a fighter for him and
they may have more ammo very soon as
this IG report is expected to come out
very soon and and Michael Horowitz may
have a lot of details that we have yet
to really have been revealed now Brett
on a slightly different topic your book
three days over Moscow the President
President Reagan for whom I used to work
all those years ago he goes over to
Moscow in 1988 it gives a speech at
Moscow State University let's think
about Korea you know whether this summit
will happen or not happen
I wonder if there'll be a day would be
great if we could have President Trump
go to North Korea or a unified Korea and
speak to a mixed group of students from
both the North and the South you think
think about how wild that would be no
one thought probably it was possible for
Reagan to go to Moscow as you write
about in your book yeah definitely not I
mean it was something that was only
dreamed about and here's a president who
was talking about anti-communist
feelings and thought
for a long time even back when he was
Screen Actors Guild president in
Hollywood and here he was standing
delivering the speech in the heart of
communism in Moscow I think it's
possible I think that this it's touch
and go with this June 12th Singapore
summit because this is the North Koreans
as you said at the beginning it's part
of laying the groundwork for what
they're trying to get done gentlemen
thanks so much